hey guys Pete here today's Game of
Thrones Season eight bonus video will be
about where things are headed now that
the night king and the White Walkers
have been defeated I rewatched episode 3
a couple times since my last video with
an intention on doing a breakdown now I
kind of feel more interested in the end
of the story though so I'm gonna talk
about that instead for what it's worth
on rewatch my feelings didn't change
much it was an amazing episode of
television objectively you can see when
they decided that Arya would be the
character to kill the night king three
years ago that they added clues to set
it up based on what they said about the
timing it seems like they decided when
they were writing season 7 and there's a
pretty clear line from there you can see
where they made things like obviously
bran giving the cat's paw dagger to Arya
and so on also in episode 3 particularly
you can see where they picked out things
from arias story to fashion the ending
of the night King around them in other
words the Melisandre conversation in
season 3 had nothing to do with the end
when it happened but the ending was
written to incorporate it I'm okay with
Arya being the one to kill the night
king in the context of that not being
the twist that was promised it was a
twist and unexpected and whether you
liked how the night king ended or not it
was clear that he would be ended we knew
he'd be defeated and he was killing
that's right off in the third episode of
six in the case that the storytellers
have something bigger they're trying to
say and I'm interested in that at this
point when I say the twist that was
promised I mean there has to be
something bigger up their sleeve to
follow Arya skill or else that will
definitely feel disappointing to me
piñon seemed to be pretty split on
episode 3 but as far as I could tell
episode 2 was really well received I
mean personally I loved it for the
character moments the dialogue the story
payoffs and most of what I saw related
to it was pretty positive as far as
reviews went this could be a good sign
if we're moving away from the
supernatural aspects and back towards
the human conflicts in King's Landing
let's not forget that just a couple
weeks ago george RR martin said that the
ending of the show wasn't going to be
much different
than the end of the books and let's also
not forget that this is a story that
revolves around internal conflicts with
the White Walkers out of the way I think
we can make some broad strokes
predictions but we're pretty much in
uncharted territory so I'm just going
off what we've seen in the past few
seasons I'm sure some of this will be
wrong but these are some of the things
I'm thinking about after episode three
drop the idea on us that the
supernatural threat had ended
obviously the Iron Throne and its
current occupant are gonna have to be
taken care of I have to confess it on a
personal level I don't hate Cersei being
the big bad at least as far as how it
draws a comparison between humanity and
a magical army of killing machine as in
what's worse a magical killing army or
human that uses that threat for their
own personal gain Plus Cersei is a
complicated character that isn't purely
evil I brought this up in several videos
after the first trailer came out but
still didn't really think we would be
sitting here looking at that taking up
the next two episodes I liked it as an
idea but I think it would be hard to
make that work and of course I'm not
condoning throwing out the themes and
everything else that was going on the
story that got us here but this is where
we're at I think there will have to be
some serious heavy lifting involved and
then pulling off an ending in the bane
of people we do it to ourselves we
destroy ourselves or people were our own
worst enemy Cersei has ratcheted up her
villainy by double-crossing everyone
else but she's basically alone at this
point she has zombie Mountain
Qyburn and Euron at her side and
everyone expects her to die before the
end of the series I'm not sure where the
twist that was promised comes from to
make Cersei by herself versus everyone
else feel more epic than the perceived
struggle of the long night we have four
hours left of the story to go and I
think this probably indicates that there
is going to be an epilogue segment in
Episode six I was never really sure if I
liked this idea but now it seems like
they have to put something in there to
fill up that space I don't think it
would be the whole episode like it's an
80 minute episode but it
some portion of that I think and I think
it could be good if it's done right
as far as Circe being the big bad I
think it will have to rely on her upping
her position right now she probably has
a better army but I mean she has to do
something to make up for the fact that
nobody else were invested in is
associated with her side besides some
crazy badass
twist we can't see coming I imagine she
could do this in two ways have someone
who is currently on John and Danny side
become a turn cloak or get a hold of a
valuable hostage I think something along
those lines will happen but don't see a
clear candidate for who the trader might
be Tyrion Varys or Sansa are the players
that are left and all of them have good
reason not to want to team up with
Cersei I do expect that she'll die since
the villain can't win and I think that
Daenerys will as well
that's been my prediction since before
the season started and nothing's really
changed that so far it's possible that
John could go out instead of Dany but I
don't see them both living I lean
towards the nurse because even though I
like her story I think it's problematic
that her claim is her birthright and her
dragons unless like John and the Dragons
die and she ends up being the queen of
the ashes I think her story more likely
ends in sacrifice than her being the
last one standing I think John will end
up being the only one with a claim by
default and I do think it would be a
terrible ending if he were the ruler
when it fades to black so I think it's
more likely that he would walk away from
the opportunity to become the king of
the Seven Kingdoms and this will open up
the door to a different form of
government with only three episodes left
it's hard to see the political intrigue
getting too complicated I have a feeling
that most of the story that isn't
dedicated to getting rid of Cersei will
involve John into nurses struggles this
doesn't seem like it's enough in and of
itself since it's hard to imagine them
actually turning on each other I think
they will end up together or whatever it
is they'll get that worked out but then
I think like one of them has to go I do
also think that it's been heavily
foreshadowed in the show that she would
become
I still think it's a likely part of the
story but I really don't know how that
would play out when you think about
things like if aria was the best
candidate to kill the night king based
on her adventures and her training
there's a pretty reasonable conclusion
that Sansa is the best character left to
actually rule based on her story and
what we've seen this isn't a new idea
it's been out there for quite a while
and I do think that she's been prepared
to do that but I don't really like the
idea of anybody sitting on the Iron
Throne at the end so I hope that her
role will be in setting up the
government rather than ruling as some
kind of a monarch and I think that
extends to just the north in general as
well I mean who knows what's even left
of the North right now but the idea of
just breaking back up into separate
kingdoms isn't that much of a move
forward either so I'd like to see
something in the form of a government
take the place of the system that we've
seen has been pretty rough on the
inhabitants of Westeros there are two
other Lannister's who are surviving I'm
really wondering why you would keep
Jaime alive through that battle if it
isn't to kill Cersei so I'm presuming
that that is his purpose I could be
wrong and that's fine but it seems like
he should have died in the battle if not
if he didn't have a purpose as far as
the endgame I don't really see him
turning back to Cersei I mean he could
be the turn cloak but that would seem a
bit out of left field based on what
we've seen transpire between him and
Brienne since he's been in the north
I don't think Arya would be the one who
would kill Cersei at this point because
like she killed the night king it's not
great as far as a reason other than she
can't kill everybody can she I mean it's
not a story about Arya she's just one of
the characters in the ensemble bran is
an absolute wild card because his story
could just be over like his story could
be complete there is a possibility that
there's more to the white Walker aspect
of the story but I doubt there would be
a full return of that threat in the
little time that we
laughs I think it's more likely that we
get an indication that they could return
rather than an actual return and I'm not
saying I like this I'm not saying that I
necessarily like any of this I'm hoping
that there's more to brand story and
there's more to what's going on with the
supernatural aspect of things but I
don't think we can say that that's
definitely going to happen based on how
much time's left and where we're at it
seems completely odd like if nothing
else it seems completely odd that
there's no balance like yeah Melisandre
died but the way that battle played out
it's almost like the Lord of Light made
it happen and good just defeated evil
and and I really don't want to get into
all that here because you could talk
about that for quite a bit there's a lot
of problems that come out of that one
thing I think is actually important
though is is that since the night King
was defeated in Episode three most of
Westeros really felt no impact from the
long night they never went beyond
Winterfell so John and Daenerys did this
heroic thing set this all in motion
Arya killed this existential threat but
there's really no way to even explain
that horror to the other people because
they didn't experience it so those are
the major things I'm thinking about
right now I'll be interested to see what
you guys think there's got to be a twist
there has to be something that we don't
see coming that they're planning for so
give me your ideas about that in the
comments I think there may be something
to the fact that we saw bran and Tyrion
have a conversation or start a
conversation that was cut off
I think Tyrion probably picked his brain
about something that might turn out to
be important my initial reaction was is
that through that he would find out
about who John actually is because John
isn't really going around telling people
about it but I don't know that that
really changes what Tyrion would be up
to like I don't know that that would
make him change allegiance from Daenerys
so he might have picked up some
information that he might try to use and
that might backfire and cause problems I
mean a lot of people have been talking
about Tyrion betraying Daenerys it seems
unlikely on the surface but then at the
same time one of these major characters
has to have
some kind of dramatic shift if these
last couple episodes are gonna be full
of something that's gonna keep us
interested so I'm gonna end it there let
me know what you think let me know what
you're thinking about where you think
the story's going what do you think the
big twist will be the twist that was
promised do you think that it's
something that's already out there in
the world of theories or do you think
there's something that's really
unexpected coming please like the video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
follow along with the rest of the season
thanks for watching guys I will talk to
you soon